hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play tracked an
indie horror game okay this one's a more
simplistic game as far as I can tell me
there's got to find something to get out
which is pretty similar theme in these
games but I will give it a try it's a
pixelated style game with which is very
similar to other games that we've played
before there's from gamejolt you can
find it in the description if you want
to play for yourself
so we seem to be in if I heard something
okay I'm hearing things from the last
game I just played I'm hearing things
okay I'm not I'm not it's not in my mind
I'm actually hearing things what is that
not a breathing is that my breathing
look at that lovely tree okay crash it
game crashes when it makes it stupid
game that's not a problem
alright so hey look at that we're back
what the hell I didn't even get any
warning I just heard up yeah I know huh
my god staring at this tree here they're
dead wood whoa okay so let's play to you
so I don't even know what I'm gonna find
I think I've looked to find keys I can't
move what did you just say I can't move
why can't I move now I see can't climb
that tree is that what you're trying to
do Oh are we just are we stuck in a tree
did we spawn in a place where we're
literally stuck in a tree climb this is
so tall look at it's almost as tall as I
am ah dammit
just kill me monster are you out there
I'm stuck in a tree I'm just gonna tie
myself up on this tree and I'm gonna
take off all my clothes and the other
monster oh he's gonna get me oh no oh oh
no he's gonna get me I'm so scared
oh oh where is he I'm waiting
live bait oh is that a breezy I heard
mr. monster fresh me
no not gonna take my enticing gift okay
well I guess we gotta restart the game
damn it again because we got spawned in
a freaking tree okay now we can move
okay no tree can I climb this Beus can I
boot climb the Boosh oh that's me
breathing okay so cuz yum I'm exerting
myself so difficulty Lili running
through this area Hey look a key I found
it how do I get out of here
not like that you don't do that you
don't sprint directly into the monster
that's not good I don't think the area
that I'm in is very big so I just gotta
find the key and get out that's all
right that's it that's all and I'm
driving it like it's got to be very
careful cuz of monster there's like not
very much okay there's the key oh
there's two keys oh how many keys do I
need I don't know if that's a health bar
right god I got no time to react when he
pops up this game is dumb this game I
can't believe it this is stupid
okay one more time okay one more time
because like doesn't I could deal cuz as
soon as a monster pops up if I'm not
like walking backwards already then
that's what I'll do that's all I'll beat
the mother I'll just walk backwards
through the whole game yeah yeah that's
it take very creeping slow steps okay
there were keys here before but
apparently not now I was so so so to
audio clue it was coming up all day you
son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] okay
I'm done
what the hell is that one of those
different than all the other ones
because the game didn't actually crash
it just exited why screw you game ignore
my smiles I'm very angry at you
alright try that for yourself see if it
works out a little better for you guys
so that's all for now so thank you all
up and watch and click the end of these
for videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]
Oh